Georgia where riot police are moving in
on protesters near the country's
parliament police use water cannon to
disperse demonstrators from earlier
protesters set up barricades around
Parliament to prevent MPs from entering
they're calling for early elections
after Parliament failed to pass a
promised electoral reform bill let's go
to our correspondent Robin Forestier
Walker he's joining as a I believe on
the phone from Tbilisi seeing reports
that police are detaining a protesters
Robin what's happening there hello yes
right now I am standing outside the
parliament where crowds of people are
still standing but they've been cleared
from the main streets and some side
streets leading around the building the
main building of the Parliament where
earlier they had two tents and erected
sandbags and they had had locked the
gate closed the entrance gates to
Parliament but the police we saw them
earlier moved in very quickly in riot
gear pushing the protestors further down
to the area outside the front of the
building and then using water cannon to
extinguish the fires there the processes
that led to keep warm and ripping up the
tents the the 10 camera they set up and
basically clearing people off
I have not myself seen any arrests at
this stage is quite possible there being
some detentions but I think the overall
aim of the government was to clear
people very quickly off the streets as
soon as they began this action which was
the basically blockade Parliament
because they say this Parliament no
longer has any credibility after that
promised by the government was reneged
apart they had promised to change the
electoral law through an a proportional
representation that would have allowed
for more reflective both next he
reversed the popular vote in the country
they reneged on that have you made that
from its early mr. man that's why
opposition protesters came out in
response to that that move in Parliament
to say time for a change they want the
government to result in but the way the
government now has responded so
decisively makes it look as if there's
potential for trouble ahead especially
if the opposition that I'm going going
willing to go quietly and robbing this
is the second day I take it off these
protests something like 20,000 people
rallied in Tbilisi to bleachy on Sunday
in several thousand when I was difficult
engaged it was pretty busy pretty packed
last night and that's when they decided
that they were going to stay on and and
and make this statement which was
effectively we have no confidence in
this government anymore the latest in a
you know in a long-running standoff
between the opposition and the
government which really began in the
summer when people came out angry at the
way the government was handling its
ongoing crisis with Russia because
Russia continues to control Georgian
territory 20% of Georgian territory and
people are angry that the government
here seen has been too soft on Russia
not being proactive enough about getting
those territories back they also feel
that there is a informal ruler of this
country which is the country's richest
man a billionaire Anagha who happens to
be the chairman of the governing party
and they seen all of the blame on him
and they think that he is basically
moving to consolidate his power his
control over this country and so this is
an ongoing to speed and ongoing calm
context between the opposition we say
the country's had enough of this
government and the government which by
the way if you know me to go anywhere or
complete to any of the opposition's
demand Robin thank you for that for now
that is Robin Forestier Walker with the
latest on those protests joining us on
the phone from the capital Tbilisi thank
you